it is a rare privilege to be here in the
great city of chicago thank you
it really is
this is
this is ladies and gentlemen this is my
first chance ever to act like a jackass
in the central time zone
let's do a little history first you
should know this chicago of course was
discovered in 1673 by father jacques
marquette and canadian explorer louis
juliet
yeah
their first words were this is the land
of milk and honey now let's fry it and
cover it with cheese
you know i am proud to be here in
chicago though and we're in such a nice
space and the people here are so nice i
promise you all i promise you all
tonight a very classy week that's right
we're going to do a classy show
in fact
[Applause]
in fact it gives me great pleasure to
announce that our show's most degenerate
reprehensible character the masturbating
bear will not
will not
be making any appearances here it's not
going to happen
not going to happen
i don't care
you do all you want i do not care
[Applause]
doesn't matter to me
the masturbating bear is in new york and
there's nothing he can do about it
i hear an airplane
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
the masturbating bear never has so much
money been spent on something so stupid